[Música]
corre el tiempo vamos sin excusas para
no activar nos y para no asumir retos y
el mío fue este mi amigo guillem me dijo
paula tú qué trabajas 24 horas al día
has conseguido hacer deporte y encima
disfrutar de él te atreves o serías
capaz de intentar en aprox 10 minutos y
en este metro cuadrado demostrar que sí
que si podemos y sobre todo tira a
romper esas barreras que nos ponemos
esas excusas o esas limitaciones así que
aquí me tenéis como dice el escritor
albert espinosa si arriesga t porque
está siempre la respuesta así que vamos
a romper todos esos muros y limitaciones
que nos ponemos y os voy a demostrar por
qué tenemos que hacer deporte y en este
pequeño espacio cómo se puede hacer yo
os he dicho que trabajo 24 horas
consultora explicar habitual gente en
varias universidades embajadora de
marcas viajes de acá para allá pero eso
no me ha impedido incorporar el deporte
en mi día a día de hecho es uno de mis
principales motores y lo que quiero
conseguir es que ese vivir corriendo tan
tóxico tan estresante que tenemos en el
que responsabilidades niño
es corriendo de acá para allá todos le
damos la vuelta y lo veamos en positivo
que es de vivir corriendo gracias al
deporte ya sea corriendo andando o
gateando lo que hagamos sea vivir riendo
es decir disfrutando del deporte y por
supuesto de la vida porque hacemos
deporte sencillamente y quedamos con
esto de verdad porque el deporte es vida
el deporte tiene muchísimos beneficios
físicos mentales anímicos nos refuerza
la masa muscular desde luego que mejora
nuestro sistema cardiorrespiratorio el
inmunológico el funcionamiento mental y
por tanto la productividad y el alto
rendimiento que tanto necesitamos nos
hace sentir mucho más fuertes nos hace
realmente más fuertes y nos empoderan y
luego sobre todo a mí lo que más me
gusta es que potencia los valores del
deporte la capacidad de sacrificio de
superación la lealtad el trabajo en
equipo y eso extrapolado a nuestro día a
día nos hace desde sacar todo el
potencial que llevamos dentro y ser
muchísimo mejor personal así que eso
tengamos lo muy presente y sigamos
lo principal que pereza o excusas bueno
no puede ser no tiene cabida y os voy a
demostrar os voy a dar unos cuantos
consejos que normalmente funcionan en
primer lugar lo que os decía de los
beneficios tengamos lo muy presente es
que tenemos en nuestras manos la
posibilidad de mejorar mucho nuestra
calidad de vida en segundo lugar lo que
podemos hacer es buscarnos un partner un
compañero con el que motivarnos y
retroalimentarnos en tercer lugar
siempre solemos tener miedo a una
disciplina nueva a una distancia mayor
olvidémonos en las primeras veces son
muy bonitas y todo seguro que sonreímos
recordar nuestra primera vez pues
llenemos nuestra vida de primeras veces
y probemos cosas nuevas por supuesto que
sí en cuarto lugar en quinto ya no sé a
mí es que no me hacen falta demasiadas
motivaciones pero sí quiero deciros
recalcar nos por ejemplo el hecho de que
nos tenemos que divertir haciendo
deporte y sobre todo adaptarlo a
nuestras circunstancias a mí me encanta
esquiar me encanta el trail la montaña
el dry porque porque la montaña es vida
es inspiración es mi refugio es muy
fuerza total
y qué pasa yo me partido la rótula este
verano corriendo en dos operados he
estado unos cuantos meses en reposo en
reposo quiere decir si no hacer deportes
de impacto pero qué opción tenía
quedarme quieta me quedé evidentemente
no pero qué haces es te adaptás las
circunstancias empecé a nadar necesitaba
un poco fluir mentalmente el deporte es
mi válvula de escape y noté un poco como
en una cárcel no y luego segundo también
empecé a meditar porque yo creo además
que el bienestar empieza con un
entrenamiento desde dentro esta vorágine
profesional que llevamos todos pues hay
veces que hay que pararlo y que sentir
no el presente la hora y am y desde
luego la meditación en este parón que he
tenido yo de ejercicio pues me ha venido
muy bien y me ha ayudado motivados vale
vamos a decir sí lo siguiente no tengo
tiempo ahora qué puedo hacer pero lo voy
a demostrar como en muy poquito
conseguiremos hacer unos ejercicios
mínimos para que realmente aporten a
nuestro bienestar aprovechemos primeros
desplazamientos todos nos movemos de un
lado para otro intentemos planificar los
para ir andando para subir escaleras en
lugar del ascensor
con cinco pisos de escaleras ya quemamos
60 calorías con una hora caminando
quemamos unas 300 yo siempre intento
cuando viajo que viajo a menudo llevarme
mi kit de running y aprovecho en reunión
y reunión
unos kilómetros y conocer un poquito las
ciudades no siempre se puede ir ganando
kilómetros y ganando vida en segundo
lugar también en el trabajo
verdad que todos tenemos muchas horas no
no me dan se puede y os voy a demostrar
como y sobre todo porque a nuestro
cuerpo está creado para el movimiento
nuestros engranajes necesitan estar
trabajados para que para no oxidarse y
sobre todo para evitar lesiones entonces
vamos a hacer dos ejercicios reparadores
muy sencillos y que veréis que repetidos
varias veces al día os van a ayudar a
sentiros muy bien así que os tengo que
pedir por favor que os levantéis porque
lo voy a demostrar
gracias a todos por vuestra colaboración
gracias vamos a empezar empezamos con
movilizaciones articulares de acuerdo
vamos a empezar por tobillos todos mover
los tornillos que en cierto
hacia un lado y hacia afuera lo mismo
con el otro
venimos con rodillas delante de ti atrás
o no
mientras seguimos con las caderas y
además nos quedan muchos bailes a temas
de movimiento hacia un lado todo lo sexy
que queramos y hacia el otro
y seguimos con las muñecas
continuamos para esperar
con los hombros miraba con él al lado y
delante hacia atrás y el cuello un
balance y atrás como vice hemos
implicado en articulaciones la
asistencia 2 y ahora vamos a estirar
nuestros
nuestra mesa nuestra silla
la pierna de atrás totalmente inspirada
muy estirada con mucha fuerza como
podéis
la de adelante flexionada y sin rebote
pero apretando encima
ahora la parte delantera del cuádriceps
agujeros en el tobillo
[Música]
y ese equilibrio que tenemos todos
y estiramos y parecidos
un perfecto
viendo como dice
es facilito notan cómo la tensión tira
mucho mucho hacia dentro
seguimos con el tríceps
pero muy ágiles a todos fenomenal
ahora el hombro un corte de manga aunque
no siempre
repetiríamos por el otro lado y ahora la
espalda que tomar liberador y lo que más
tarda con el estrés
la recordamos
y nos asociamos con las manos tiran
mucho una y otra una y otra todo lo que
podáis
ahora nos vamos subiendo en redondo
poquito a poco arqueados otra vez
entrelazar las manos
y tirarlas arriba muy alto muy alto muy
alto ponemos de puntillas y podéis tocar
el cielo
y aflojar
ya padecen todos
muchas gracias
sencillito verdad si alguien me dice es
que no tengo tiempo para hacer
movilización de articulaciones músculos
y tal
tururú hemos visto que se puede de
acuerdo pero hay que seguir un poquito
más llegamos a casa no tenemos tiempo no
bueno nos ponemos cómodos
[Música]
y
todos podemos ponernos cómodos en cinco
e incluso unos segunditos de acuerdo y
ahora vamos a hacer 10 minutos en todos
tenemos 10 minutos en casa vamos a hacer
tres ejercicios multifuncionales
equilibrio la parte inferior y la parte
superior
empezamos por las clásicas sentadillas
[Música]
apretamos por el cuerpo para intentar
total
al subir apretamos
[Música]
si queremos explicarlo
con el amor aseguró
[Música]
me motiva
por si alguno se atreve a superar este
movimiento y acabaríamos por
aspiraciones a voluntad con una
respiración esta cuerda porque hay que
relajar el cuerpo ojos cerrados
hombros muy relajados
inspiramos llenando la capa torácica
inspiramos a vaciarnos del todo 510
veces la serenidad con la que luego nos
quedamos desde luego que es muy
gratificante ver esto será muy sencillo
esto yo quería demostrar como en el
trabajo desplazamientos y 10 minutos en
casa nada más llegar que nos cambiamos
podemos hacerlo pero es cierto que yo os
recomiendo que busquéis un poquito más
de tiempo para hacer deporte de calidad
para intentar llevar una vida bienestar
completa con ejercicios aeróbicos cardio
salto nadar con anaeróbicos que es la
fuerza que es la antioxidante y luego
flexibilidad yo soy un leño nos quedamos
totalmente abarrotado es verdad
nutrición sana y descanso reparador con
esto voy a cerrar con unas conclusiones
que mi tiempo también está a puntito de
acabarse esta soy yo disfrutando y
llenando me de vida mientras corría la
desert run lo que quiero hacer es con lo
que he pretendido demostraros es que no
es cuestión de tiempo sino de ganas que
el deporte nos llena de una actitud
positiva ante la vida nos ayuda a
disfrutarla mucho más y con más calidad
entonces quiero invitaros realmente a
que hagáis también vuestro mile
y os explico las ganas de superación
propias del deporte yo las he volcado en
lo que se ha convertido en la
competición de mi vida que es que a reír
no te gané nadie así que con esto y por
qué pues porque al final yo tengo
motivos para reírme pero es que si no
los tengo los busco porque hago todo por
reírme y reírme por todo y porque yo
creo desde luego que vivir corriendo es
vivir riendo y ahora sí el último favor
porque ya cerramos con esto os pido de
nuevo os levantéis ya acabamos
que hagáis esta posición los brazos en
una uve muy grande muy grande muy fuerte
de vida v de vida y que a la de 3
gritéis conmigo yo me pido vida una dos
y tres yo me pido vida
gracias